speaking of the grift is there anyone
more griftery than the ladies of the
view I think not here's noted racist
Sunny Hosten and she used to be on CNN
and she's laying into CNN and her former
friend Anderson Cooper I think that you
don't give a bigot and a racist and a
misogynist and a liar and cheater and a
sexual abuser and a defamer a platform
of three million people and I'm saddened
uh I used to work for CNN for quite some
time Anderson Cooper has been my friend
for over 20 years and I'm saddened that
he tried to Gaslight me yesterday by
saying that people are in silos people
aren't living in a silo they are
choosing to listen to the lies or not
46.9 percent of people voted for Trump
in 2020 but he lost the popular vote by
over 7 million people we know who this
man is we learned who this man is and we
did not need to see what we saw I think
that that town hall will be studied in
journalism schools around the country as
to what not to do it was not fact
checked appropriately I don't believe it
again
can I just not be interrupted for a
second
um she didn't have the rain
he agreed to the interview because he
knew he could steamroll her that's not
fair Jake Tapper would have done a
better job and I will tell you that
remember Trump walked out of a 16
minutes interview with Leslie Stahl
because she was fact-checking him in
real time every single time it's time
for some real introspection at CNN
because I often thought like just judge
uh Brandeis because the Supreme Court
Justice actually brandeised that
sunlight is said to be the best of
disinfectants this time that's what this
is no CNN went with les moonves this was
a business decision Les moonves said
this was awful for the country but it
was good for CBS This was awful for the
country CBS
awful for the country but
congratulations CNN for making a little
bit of money on the backs of our
democracy you're right lady and as one
of the prime purveyors of lies in this
country on that Daily Show every day
which is on ABC right now and thank God
you good people aren't watching it
because you're with me right this moment
you spread this stuff you spread the
lies so you don't mind lies you just
want people to swallow your lives and
also keep in mind there is no Republican
that Sunny Hostin or the rest of these
types of people wouldn't say is a bigot
and a racist and a homophobe and a
transform and everything else right like
they think Trump is the threat right now
but as DeSantis continues to rise and
it's very obviously like that that
that's on the cusp of happening right
now
um you're going to see the same as exact
attacks on him actually we've seen them
already and what do I keep saying
they're going to call them Hitler with a
calculator he's going to be Trump but oh
my God he's actually functional this is
is going to be a real problem for these
people
[Music]
foreign